[Applause]
in
in in in in my northern stars welcome
back
[ __ ] well done how'd you feel about
this oh absolutely fantastic
yes out of this world good very excited
to be back
out there are some very discerning
demanding clients
yeah customers that are expecting the
best of the best yeah
bloody good to have you back thank you
good to be here let's get going yeah
right time for the start yes king crab
tortellini yes
ready yes sir first susan yeah we're
gonna kill the crab
oh yeah oh don't look it don't don't
don't turn your nose up out of that yeah
of course
here hold the crap hold the crab
take the crab for god's sake woman let's
go
right on here please excuse me if you're
gonna
cook it you're gonna have to kill it
first i'm not making killing it i can't
touch it
susan you're acting like a soft southern
jessie come on stop [ __ ] around
in there through there knife on there
very carefully and bang straight through
and then we crunch through through there
okay got to kill it quickly okay
say goodbye to him first what's he
called you name it
bye gordon through put your hand through
quick straight away
okay good good girl right excellent now
we're going to take off the cluster
through yes there's one cluster hold it
please
hold it there you go and there's your
second cluster in the water nice
bring it back to the boil cook it yeah
okay good right on order first table yes
four covers table two four total an e4
lamb
four chocolate souffle yes yeah right
let's get on with the tortellinis yes
we're gonna serve two tortellinis per
portion yes
yes yes two thirds of a spoon and we
just egg wash
half judith why do we do that let's make
it stick that's right
up into your hands push and nipple the
air out you ladies have got disciplined
fingers you can do that yeah
yeah chef okay right let's just quickly
go through the sauce together yeah
lemongrass
olive oil yes it's like a sort of tomato
olive oil sauce yes shallots in there
we've got our basil our coriander
tomatoes in and just leave that
cooking away all right top liners let's
go one and a half minutes
gently boiling water right sauce out
ready to serve pasta's cooked and then
from there
on to the plate king crab tortellini
we're a fresh tomato and lemongrass
vinaigrette
are you happy with those yes yeah would
you pay for them
table 10 there jb please yes cue family
wedding store
sandra apparently you upset your mum
last time you're on the f word yes by
swearing is that right
yes chef i had a pep talk before we left
this morning me and susan
was about to walk out of the door
imperial level is not good i had to have
my mouth washed out with it after my
mother saw that program
yeah seriously why do i always get the
blade i don't mean to swear you know
it's the company i'm in
trust me ladies it's [ __ ] great to
have you back
that's nice let's go table 9 here
very nice uh susan you're in charge of
the hot plate well i'm gone for 30
seconds okay
keep this area nice and tidy yes chef
[ __ ] yeah
does that mean i check them
hello johnny how are you how are you
doing nice to see you
yeah yeah your starter yeah fantastic so
good to see you
yeah no it's so good to be here you're a
very brave man later we're head to head
on the recipe challenge how did you find
your chances
i've really found some reasons i think
it's something that's beyond you
i think you've developed beyond simple
good food seriously let me just show you
where we're going to be cooking can have
a quick look at the kitchen yes okay
i'll show you give you a head start so
you've got some no ladies
hey i don't bring you to chat work the
room
these ladies are also from lancashire
ladies please johnny
yes jonathan here we go let's go
come round come around come here check
it out
this is susan darling
yes sandra and justine right
right vegas out of the kitchen i'll see
you guys
don't cook for them cook for you get out
get up
get johnny vegas out of this kitchen now
please yes bloody hell
[Music]
like me hugh the shaggy sheep farmer
doesn't like to waste anything
i've just slaughtered my sheep and have
invited you for the wooden store around
for tea
yeah busy day at the avatar yeah
extraordinary day
here to help me cook up a family feast
with some of the more unusual cuts
the most amazing brains and the breads
wow they are extraordinary it's a little
while since i've cooked sheep's brains
really
so you've got the two different types of
sweet bread something the long thin one
obviously being the throat
glands yep and they're the heart yeah
look at them they're beautiful huh huh
very tender
seems really weird haven't taken them
out myself this will certainly be the
freshest set of brains i've ever worked
really
now do you think tana and the kids will
eat sweet breads and brains
tarnell definitely jack will definitely
the girls i'm not too sure you know that
good to have your garden back um it will
be yeah when it's all done but
uh i don't know it's really weird with
it now as you start to miss him isn't it
where is gavin now he's up in
oxfordshire roaming around and having
some fun
has he still got his knackers yes so he
can be a breeding round
i think he's going to have a retirement
what an extraordinary turn of fortunes
for him i know
bro i'm just going to quickly sweat off
these um you're way ahead of me now
onions no don't worry you give me a
crumb job again
i'm caramelizing my onions in muscovado
sugar gives a really nice dark
rich semi spice and then just gonna put
some
balsamic vinegar in there and just sort
of caramelize them almost like an onion
marmalade
i'm gonna put mine in slowly i'm gonna
color them slowly get nice and crispy
and then they'll take
about eight to ten minutes to cook okay
look at that
i'm gonna lightly approach i'm gonna pop
them in now actually
all i'm gonna do is saute the veg
poach the brains and saute the brains
and put the two together
nice leave the cool down
far off my garlic first slice the sweet
breads up now they've cooled down
just set nicely these brains nice it's
like poaching an egg
how lucky are the kids fried lamb brains
and caramelized
sweet breads with a marmalade of onion
capers
and vinegar you know what i was going to
do just the
lightest sprinkling of cider vinegar
already on the brains themselves
that is [ __ ] pretty
right sit down two very exciting dishes
hey hugh yours is it's uh brains with
baby spring vegetables and mint
mmm and this is throat glands
and it's selling it so well it's sweet
breads
meg i'm not hungry sweet breads are
absolutely delicious the brains
um it's a very unusual texture very nice
i did like it
i prefer the braids yeah i've already
had seconds
hands up your deep brains again
[Music]
how about you dig a pond and get
yourself a couple of crocodiles
giraffes
i thought it was lovely i thought it was
presented very nicely and
so many flavors coming through i really
enjoyed it yeah why are we eating these
things with
legs and shells i'm sure it was happier
in the thing that its flesh was already
in and
with this it can't even walk sideways
i feel like i've insulted the chef who
is the chef
okay right ladies come over please
results yes
starters yes were they happy very happy
yeah right give me here we go
thank you okay the amount of customers
they're happy to pay for their totalling
of king crab out of 50
46. very good
very very good well done
what do you say too much pasta and not
enough crab
discs
okay the best so far next on the menu
the lancashire lassies go commando
what and my very special shepherd's pie
proves a problem for ricky gervais
where's it gonna end you and jeremy
clarkson
in a helicopter shooting their cousins
they're so tasty
[Applause]
welcome back to the f word time for the
main course my lambs now i'm doing them
two ways
first up lego lamb
leg of lamb the king of all joints sweet
tender
very rich and absolutely delicious a
must-have for every dining table
get your butcher to bone it out and
butterfly it basically so you can tie it
and roast it hot oven
season olive oil
mint use it in abundance it's fresh
it's fragrant smells amazing
goat's cheese the mint perfumes the
inside of the lamb
and the goat's cheese just sort of makes
the center nice and creamy
garlic roll
[Music]
first of all a big loop around the lamp
that keeps it all in shape
get a nice length of string tie a knot
right at the very top underneath and
leave it coming out here
the secret of tying it this shape helps
to cook it evenly
and look beautiful
rosemary season
gets the skin really nice and crispy
olive oil
stops the string from burning so
therefore it won't burst open while it's
in the oven
and bingo roast 35 minutes
rest carve
mint vinaigrette
[Applause]
[Music]
that has confirmed it's definitely the
king of roasts
roast leg of lamb with ghost cheese and
mint
done now i'm nicely seasoned
how long does this go in the oven part
about 35
to 40 minutes right in yeah special lamb
as you know it's going to be rested for
literally the same time as it's cooked
so it's nice and pink it'll keep warm
while it's resting all the time
absolutely definitely without a doubt so
it's really important now to get some
colour on the lamb
yeah yeah okay up
okay good
tonight i'm serving the lamb two ways
you've seen the leg and this is the
nation's favorite
[Music]
shepherd's pie a great british classic
absolutely delicious
mints vegetables potatoes easy
olive oil minced lamb
a little bit of color on the mince and
it gets rid of that unwanted fat
there's nothing worse than a greasy
shepherd's pie
season great onion
carrot
garlic once the vegetables are grated in
there they disintegrate and almost puree
adding great flavor and that's the
secret behind a really good shepherd's
pie
it's all in the mints what's the sauce
tomato puree
red wine
thyme rosemary right now the red wine's
evaporated
chicken stock in and cook it out for
three or four minutes
no more than that
[Music]
potatoes mash
season egg yolks
[Music]
now secret ingredient parmesan cheese
be quite generous with the parmesan
because that's what gets it really nice
and golden brown
[Applause]
now deserves to sit on top of my mince
[Applause]
[Music]
good old-fashioned tip just to keep my
mom happy
for the top 18 to 20 minutes in the oven
beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
the crispy topping you can see what that
deserves to be a great british classic
shepherd's pie done
46 out of 50 for the starter try and get
50 out of 50 for the lamb yes
yep tonight yeah it's all about
perfection yeah let's do it out of
respect for my lambs yes
yes yes judith and susan five portions
away please yeah yeah yeah
let's go carrots take out and leave on
the top there yes
okay let's go ladies yes chef nice let
me put the lemon on there
keep the round [ __ ] up to the top nice
carousel right nice not too oily please
ladies service please
yeah table six please yes
ladies i'm getting very nervous you're
very quiet what's the matter with
concentrating chair
really what i want to know is that a
little birds told me that your commander
in the kitchen i was 21 years of age for
god's sake
i don't command her anymore yeah but we
just
[Music]
it's like a pair of curtains they're not
knickers are they oh my
god almighty oh now it's time for tribe
a forgotten food that i personally
want to put back on the menu
it may look disgusting but i love a bit
of tripe now it's very cheap
very nutritious but sadly these days
you've got to go through a hell of a lot
of [ __ ] to get hold of it
tripe is the lining of a cow's stomach
it has been voted britain's least
favorite food
which i think is a waste in my
grandparents day everyone
ate tribe and i'm determined to put it
back on the map
i love tribe i grew up with tribe it's
been in the family for years and
having lived in france in italy that's
all we used to eat for staff lunch was
tribe
i've managed to get my hands on some
fresh cows guts and brought them to a
tripe dresser
before i can cook with them peter how
are you
likewise good to see you tomorrow man
hey now it's down to you to turn into
something
some magical physical in 1900 there were
200 tribe dresses in britain
your great great grandfather now there
are only three
and the smell i mean this place just
stinks of tribe
now what does the wife say when you get
home uh she doesn't she doesn't she left
she left all right peter and i
boil my tripe to make it more tender
look like you've been doing it for years
and then bleach it to improve the color
it's hard to believe that's the same try
you know in terms of you know
how palatable it looks now peter
supplies bob and christine
who run a traditional tribe stall at the
market in akron and stanley
hi buddy how are you good to see you
well christine
now you've been selling for how long
their customers love tribes so much here
they even eat it raw now uh how are you
going to cook that what are you going to
do with the tribe
the whole one eat it as it did as it is
with salt and vegetables
and easy
to find out who's actually buying bob's
tribe i'm going to give him a hand on
the store thank you
oh that's nice and cozy in here now
isn't it good morning madam you guys are
trying my darling yes
you know what you're gonna do with it
vinegar yes a little bit of
my madam how old are you please 91 on
saturday 91 on saturday
many happy returns for saturday morning
sir what are you going to have this
morning jelly
on your girl is that for tonight's
dinner no no actually
just really at home that's just for a
snack good man
good man the fact that just been here
for the last five minutes and watching
you know the customers come and pick up
the tripe how old they are
and in a way that you know there's not
enough youth eating it
try it ladies is there anyone out there
under the age of 30 who would like to
buy some tribe
tribes clearly got an image problem and
many young people haven't even tried it
so with bob's help i'm setting up my
very own belly deli
to reinvent it as a really tasty dish
i like that yeah you like that dude
gone's gut hut
yes right and but what we're gonna do is
something sort of modern
okay so pan fried tribe yes with some
lemon and parsley
if we get it looking fresh and modern a
lot more people are going to eat it
right okay first of all chop some onions
and garlic
and sweat so this is a
my way of doing tripe sort of fast you
know like fast food
then toss the tripe in some flour and
season with salt and cayenne pepper
well just to make it a little bit more
sort of um tangy and fresh
you use vinegar don't you yeah i'm gonna
grate some lemon on there
yeah and what that does it just makes it
a little bit sort of lighter
fresher a little bit more zestier yeah
and i'm gonna do now is fry it
very quickly with some sunflower oil
okay
[Music]
all right season with fresh parsley and
a squeeze of lemon
yeah now we're ready who would like some
try please
anybody here in akron hasn't eaten tribe
yes where are all the tripe virgins
you here we go why haven't you had tripe
before my darling
just because it just doesn't look very
nice at all do you like it
it's really nice actually yeah yes and
it's fried in the pan as well i think i
might try it
yeah good girl hey look all these new
customers you're getting you like it
yes how old are you 18. that's what i
want to hear
so we've gone from 90 to 18 this morning
right guys come over how are you doing
now this is zachary stanley's one under
11's this dish here
is full of protein how old are you six
do you like the try yes fantastic it's a
load of bollocks that people don't like
trope anymore because cooked in a modern
way
they love it look at this lot next time
you're out get down to your butcher and
get some try for dinner
it's delicious and healthy who would
like some tribes
no i know you don't like fancy food
enjoy the shepherd's pie absolutely
wonderful i mean shepherd's pie would be
in them i think my top five
videos and that was that was lovely the
mints for the shepherd's pie was from
the lambs that had in my back garden
so hold on so they were basically your
pets
they weren't pets you can't fall into
that habit of allowing them to become
pets
although they are very friendly to begin
with but then you've got to sort of
distance yourself from them yeah but you
say that where's it gonna end
you and jeremy clarkson in a helicopter
shooting your cousins
what i kept distance from them i didn't
really know them growing up
and they're so tasty
i'm glad you got your shirt on you
always have to show a bit of that don't
you no no no
it's for the menopause of women oh look
he's taking his shirt he walked to the
restaurant the other week
carrying a stab who do you think you are
four hold on hold on hold on
no but you enjoyed it didn't you i did
enjoy it obviously i'd rather know that
that animal
had a wonderful life absolutely killed
you mainly
gavin um escaped okay you've given it a
name
i know i know why would you do that what
would you see when you when you buy it
in tesco's there's not a name
they don't care this is bob we killed
bob
gavin didn't die charlotte unfortunately
got eaten
a wolf a suspected puma a wild cat or a
humongous fox
where where do you live with these
humans and human foxes no is it
beckoning people no this is serious
who does cooking at home i do it's
not i don't know ever no
let me tell you why gordon please i'm a
genius
and i've got to save all those skills
for other things okay i thought stephen
merchant was a genius
that can't no you're not just bloody
brilliant and making people laugh
you're also bloody fantastic making
money um the dvds
the podcast the animals have you ever
been tempted or swayed by doing an
advert
no i'm not tempted no i got offered a
million pounds to do a gin advert in
america when the office broke in america
and my i said i know you don't do
adverts but i just run this by you
and i went no i can't because i just
thought if i said yes i'd regret so i
said no
and he said they've come back with two
million they thought i was haggling
oh my god and i think it's because you
haven't had the right product okay so
i've got some
items that want you to have a look at
and tell me how you would market them in
an advert
okay first thing go on
block chocolate bar it's a delicacy in
sweden
um how aren't foreign so how would you
advertise it how would you
sit there and munch if it's a swedish
advert it would be
a really weird one wouldn't it it would
bring something like
you better put up
what's that one that that that sexy
rabbit used to advertise
cadbury's caramel now yeah yes with that
really
sexy rabbit can we cut that i've never
had sex with any rodent actually it's a
lager
okay uh this one you like soups don't
you yeah yeah
okay so it's a cock-flavoured bouillon
coke flavour excellent oh god snap it
out the great taste of car
okay finally to wash it all down it's
closer to sweden it's dead
okay this would be ninja
i'm slightly squeamish to drinks oh my
god
the
that's that smug that's been hanging
around for quite some time
how would you promote um the danish shot
of spunk vodka
that's the best funk i've ever tasted
listen really good to see you wonderful
good work thank you very much
i thought the lamb was excellent really
nicely cooked very tender and i like the
lemon zest
on the top well it was delicious the
lamb but it's a terrible shame about the
goat's cheese in the middle of it but
once you've scraped it out
of that tasted nice and tender it was a
saying that he hasn't had any stress
another good life
right results this is quite special for
me yes a lot of hard work
months getting that ready yeah in terms
of looking after them nursing them and
doing
all we can to improve that flavor yes jb
right i thought you did a bloody good
job yeah clearly the most talented
brigade we've had on so far
however yeah they are the critics
they're your customers and the amount of
customers are happy to pay for the main
course
48 out of 50.
that is not quite good
perfect yeah sweet there's room for
improvement uh jb just advertising why
didn't you pay
um who was it too much meat and too much
tomato in a pie
jb [ __ ] off back to france yes let's go
dessert
next on the menu i let my fanny loose in
the kitchen
buckles out of my kitchen but only after
you've done the washing up
and 18 stone of idiot takes me on in the
recipe challenge
i have gordon ramsay parties we all just
sit down tell each other [ __ ] off
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the f word now it's time
for me to take on 18 stone of idiots
johnny you ready yeah i'm ready nervous
no i'm not right what are you cooking
i'm cooking pizza pizza yeah very simple
very rustic food of the peasants it's
bringing working class into these
kitchens
and giving them a taste of something
substantial something real something
that we can't just drive past on a
saturday night and watch people eat and
go out of those people live
perfect now what's that the secret
machine what is that this
is my blood maker stroke door maker
because that's the one thing that i do
rely on i'm just giving a very simple
pizza
fresh tomato sauce and then top of some
really nice bay on ham just put me
flowered in which is a very
decent double zero italian flower um
what i'm gonna do now is add the olive
oil but i've got a tablespoon measurer
but it's alright i'm gonna do it by i'm
the crazy guy i am
i've got my live yeast here because i
don't like the giant powdered stuff and
you never get the right result with it
and start it mixing are you not actually
making your own pizza dough are you
putting it together machine's making it
for you no it's not what it's shooting
[ __ ] it
is it bollocks cheating [ __ ] us i know
it worked for you
you can't speak to me like this johnny
be good i am being good
i'm gonna bring water at the boil put my
yeast in oh look it be a machine it's
the work of the devil
whisk in the yeast activates it touch
a volleyball in there a touch of salt
absolutely crucial
from there flour into the normal food
processor so what what you use in your
garden is it a machine
uh this is a this is a machine is it a
machine
it's a robot does it
hey smarty pants what are you doing with
the china sauce uh tomato sauce it's
just uh
it's just me tomatoes uh salt
yeah tiny bit of sugar oregano and some
fresh basil
so johnny's making a very simple tomato
sauce out of tin tomatoes i've just got
some schlotz
and garlic and some basil here and fry
off
cherry tomatoes a few sun-dried tomatoes
so because a really nice
dry tomato sauce knead this together
[Music]
right dough is needed put that in
right that goes in should double in size
we'll knock it back and roll it out nice
and thin
right how you doing my man i'm gonna
make the pizza in three different
sections
already so i'm gonna have one with uh me
capers and me
uh anchovies and then i'm gonna make a
gorgonzola one in the middle
just for just for the veggies and then
on the other end i'm gonna have
four seasons but you're using three
seasons yeah yeah i'm look i'm just
spreading the options out anna what is
the most outrageous thing you've ever
done on stage
i did do a [ __ ] but he deserved it
on stage yeah i was in liverpool the guy
come on to review it and i went oh you
saw the comedy review and he went no
well what'd you do but i normally cover
pet shows
what the [ __ ] are you doing here so i
had somebody walk me around as if i was
a dog
you're on all fours yeah and then i
just slipped my pants down about and
just screamed
but then we had to tell them did you
wipe your ass i told them it was a
problem because with the technician
pretending it wasn't real [ __ ] it's not
even real if you lose the challenge
tonight yeah don't [ __ ] on me okay no
no i won't
[Music]
so this is my dough i'm just going to
roll it out slacken it off a little bit
and just sort of
get it really nice and pliable and then
roll it
nice and thinly you're using a rolling
pin i am using a rolling pin
so tomato on first a nice thin layer
of tomato sauce on there what kind of
mozzarella are you using the big ones or
the little baby ones uh the big ones
you're copying me again yeah i just live
you know what i mean
to follow you i could get clothes in
your style i would that's nice
ramsay parties we all just sit down tell
each other [ __ ] off
and then finish with some really nice
parma ham
right ready yeah and it goes there you
go the three seasons that you've been
taking the piss out of it looks like
[ __ ] school dinners
right so [ __ ] this isn't okay looks
nice right so then we've got that we've
got
um um obviously always all over yeah
just hammer mushroom and then they've
got the gorgonzola and then we've got
the seafood
yes people have a choice yeah in this
world
up right quad oven yep and it goes
right johnny they're in the oven now yes
yeah
10 minutes gonna have a pint come back
and you lose
no i'm gonna stay and observe because
you're paranoid
no i might need to put a little foil on
if the bit sees my base it's a little
bit thicker than yours and have made
right i'm made with passion i might have
to cover the tops i don't want the top
to overcook before the burst has got
nice and crispy
you mean you might have to get a
takeaway no it means i might have to do
a [ __ ] on yours
now it's time for dessert a delicious
hot chocolate souffle made by ravinder
who last week
i chose to be my new fanny ravinder well
done
good to see you um you're now gonna make
the most amazing hot chocolate souffle
teach the nation
yeah please don't [ __ ] it up thank you
so i'm going to show you how to make the
most indulgent decadent
hot chocolate souffle take 200 ml of
milk
add 20 grams of corn flour when it's in
a really
yogurty texture you know it's kind of
ready and there you go it's nicely
thickening up
chop the chocolate don't skimp on it
it needs to be about 60 to 70 cocoa
content because you need
to taste the chocolate in this
[Music]
add four egg yolks
it's really important that the chocolate
is a little bit cooler otherwise what
you get is this horrible scramble from
the eggs
[Music]
my mother used to say a clear work
surface is a clear mind
gordon's got all the dishes to do i hope
he's a good washropper
whisk the egg whites slowly add 150
grams of caster sugar
now remember this is what's breathing
the life into your chocolate mix so you
don't want to overwork the mixture you
don't want to get
too enthusiastic more washing for gordon
really voluptuous you can see it almost
heaving it's really sexy
butter a ramekin and dust with grated
[Music]
chocolate
clean the rim otherwise your souffle
won't rise
so just leave it alone for six minutes
do whatever you want
have sex read a newspaper i don't know
what you do in your six minutes
the perfect chocolate souffle done
lovely lovely nice nice nice i'm dying
to get in there you know that
is it good that absolutely delicious
fantastic well
yes [ __ ] off out of my kitchen but only
after you've done the washing up
you're telling me to [ __ ] off at my
kitchen
uh you're like susan you still haven't
got a boyfriend why oh
well what can i say it's really
difficult isn't it yeah
it's difficult to commit to one person
as well what about you
yeah why don't you guys go out on a
double date you and susan
kind of picked us up with some nice uh
colors
and that nice little short frenchman
like jb look over there
jp is the most
[Music]
that's amazing wrist action you got
there seriously ravinder as they come
out you serve the table go straight to
johnny vegas yes
yeah be careful johnny vegas doesn't eat
you be very careful
hands on here good girl off you go hey
johnny
enjoy
[Music]
marry me
now it's time for janice reporter to
sink her teeth into bernard matthews
now as you all know i'm a little bit of
a food snob and this kind of thing isn't
something i'd normally eat frankly i'm
surprised it's still on the shelves
cheery norfolk farmer bernard matthews
has had the smile wiped
off his face by three huge food scandals
first came turkey twizzlers bursting
with so much saturated fats
that many schools dropped them like a
stone
next came these horrifying images
employees playing baseball with live
turkeys and then just as you thought it
couldn't get any worse
one of his farms was hit by bird flu
during the outbreak it emerged that
bernard matthews that great british food
institution
actually uses large amounts of meat from
hungary
but does he tell you that on the packet
like
hell bernard matthews dinosaurs
don't know where it's come from
dinosaurs could have come from outer
space
bernard matthews jettas where they flown
in from
bernard matthews is in the middle of a
massive rebranding exercise
but being clear and honest about the
country of origin
is much more important than flashy logos
or spin
so it says turkey breast meat is often
referred to
as a superfood because it's naturally
low in fat and cholesterol
but where does it come from bernard
after 21 packets i
checked only two gave the country of
origin of the meat
well you might think that bernard's only
doing what every other turkey producer
does but you'd be wrong
take a look at this lot sainsbury's
fresh
british turkey it tells you product of
hungary
clearly marked what's bernard's problem
alberna's labeling isn't illegal but it
is potentially misleading
i think he's trading on his image as a
norfolk farmer
to make his customers think all his
turkey is english
but how does he do it simple it's all
about the packaging
all you have to do is make your product
look english
and not give any information about where
the meat comes from
i'm going to make a turkey pie using
meat from brazil poland and hungary
and see if i can convince people it's
actually english
so i've made the filling for my pie now
i'm going to put the pastry on it
and pop it in the oven here is my
packaging
turkey pie produced in england
this is perfectly legal now all i've got
to do is see if i can flog them
hi there hello jenny can i persuade you
to taste some of my
uh turkey pie mmm lovely if i told you
that the meat in that turkey pie comes
from
hungary poland and brazil yeah i'm not
going to catch nothing am i
the box is very misleading when you look
at that box
where do you think the meat and that pie
comes from i would think
it comes from england but if i put this
box on the side it said meat
from poland hungary and brazil
would you buy it more than likely not
where do you think it comes from turkey
i think we consumers have a right to
know where our meat comes from
one person who agrees is david clarke
from red tractor
the uk's leading independent food
assurance scheme
if there's a red tractor on a piece of
meat you can be a hundred percent sure
it's british
and carefully reared do you think it's
important that when people buy food they
know exactly where it's come from
absolutely i mean that's why we have
a clear statement of country of origin
within the logo therefore the consumer
cannot be confused
i think what i'm going to do is uh go to
mr matthews and ask him why he won't
sign up for your retractor scheme
i think that's a good idea i wrote to
bernard matthews explaining my concerns
asking him why he doesn't label where
his meat comes from
and demanding that he signs up to the
red tractor scheme
two weeks later here i am in central
london i've been summoned to meet
bernard matthews chief executive hi
nice to meet you bernard doesn't get out
much these days so he sent his right
hand man to answer me
i have threatened to serve bernard
matthews with a food
asbo and he'll be my second one
now but after got a whole bag full of
packaging here
but i'm looking for where
this turkey comes from
we've not realized uh it's that
important
in fact we would welcome all of the
origin of meat to come on because we'll
find that we
still are the vast majority of our stuff
comes from the uk hang on a minute bart
on the 5th of february
bernard matthews company said all our
turkeys are british
or turkey eggs come from our hatchery
and from
our laying flocks which are ours in
norfolk yeah so all our turkeys are now
those eggs may go to hungary
uh to be born but uh to be reared but
the vast majority of all of our turkeys
are in norfolk and
uh when you say all our turkeys are
british does that mean that the ones are
in hungary
their mum and dads are british certainly
yeah
but they're living in hungary yeah so
they're hungarian turkeys
the vast majority of our products come
from the uk and we're going to
very clearly signpost uh those products
that are british and what we're doing on
the back is we're going to take a lead
on it and describe when products are
british it'll be very clearly stated
it's british and
we've got agreement from red tractor so
we can use that
so you are going to put the red tractor
sign starting when
it will be by the beginning of september
so when it says under branded map is
it's going to be in here
made from turkey from our own farms or
from wherever else
so that's promise yeah by september the
1st we'll get them on
okay it's the deal
hello janet hello gordon nice to see you
my daddy you look great
thank you i dressed up for clarity first
of all congratulations yeah yeah i
do feel a real sense of achievement made
bernard matthews mr beautiful and
eating his words well done i think they
were scared of us that's a brilliant
thing and what they agreed to do what
what exactly well yeah
they're going to sign up to the red
tractor scheme so all
the meat that they use that is bread on
farms in the uk
is going to have the red tractor and
meat that comes from abroad
is going to have the country of origin
clearly labelled on
the packet bloody good news so they're
going to be far more honest which is
fantastic how is he going to stick to
what what's that
he promised me that by september this
year they will change their labeling on
their packaging and if he doesn't stick
to it what are you going to do to
go out to norfolk and deep fries perky
twizzler
i will i'll go out there bloody well
done i think you're scared more of you
as opposed to the asbo
you're not scared of me are you good
beautiful i'm not scared you're taught
my channel
lipstick next on the menu
will heavyweight johnny vegas knock me
out in the recipe challenge
look at the choice look at this like
that claridges looks nice
bnb and bogna regis
and will the girls do lancashire proud
how do you think we did
50. i hope so you know i really do
welcome back to the effort now time to
find out who is the mission-style chef
and who is the michelin man
are you ready oh yes i am ready let's
get a big boy i'm confident what are you
finishing it with
well a bit of olive oil okay oh my
anchovies
whoa i want the fresh ones from the
bottom
look at that hey looks nice here's my
baby coming out
holy mackerel look at that baby
a little bit buzzing on the top i think
your screen's michelin man screams
family
i think your screams cheese shot you
know if i do win it
go on it's late out phone calls for the
rest of your life
hey germany that's happening in that
pizza
johnny [ __ ] off look at that look now
then
now then look at the choice look at the
overall clarities
looks nice being being right all right
oh i like that sound that crispy sound
just to even it up
right hey that looks nice right listen
yeah you see i want just to pause the
stuff yeah i know no i know but you've
got three seasons and four bits of pizza
yeah especially on french artichokes i
know that taste wise that'll be
phenomenal
good i know that you know that's that's
why you earn money from it
that's why i am 18 stone right jb off
you go
yes entertainer right off you go yep uh
the three season by johnny
and uh clarity's pizza bye i'm me jimbo
you asked
two coughs when you put this down one is
exchanged ends in
you know the brown envelope in the
garage
tomatoes a real tomato not too much
cheese either
okay i swear isn't it a very different
square and a much
thicker base yeah cheesier for sure
it's actually crunchier than the other
one okay big boy
i hope you're not going to make a monkey
on me johnny b come on come on come on
come on come on come on
come on okay no very close
very very close uh it's a three two two
it's a three to two yeah so it's very
close all right
come on yeah come on okay
you're looking at me which is telling me
that you're going to say him as if
you're trying to tell me whether you
need to charge your best
it's you gordon oh yes boy
get in there well done [ __ ] for that
three two so it was close
i had money on myself
hey you can hold your head higher man
that was [ __ ] delicious cheesy but
delicious ah yeah
whatever do me a favor well take your
pizza and [ __ ] about it
never darken this restaurant again and
don't sit on the kitchen floor on the
way out
no no i'll send that to the restaurant
are you well done big boy now for all
you animal lovers out there
yes yes yes right [ __ ] it i'm gonna open
a pizzeria
[Music]
[Applause]
that's pretty careful now last two
tables and i'll dust you put them on yes
here we go and away okay we got two
sixes
thank you hey jb yes thanks for doing
your job yeah you're welcome
yeah i know france i only want to work
[ __ ] 32 hours a week but
thanks so much for coming yeah excellent
susan
yes are you giving jb the eye are you
trying to no he was telling him to mince
him up
no because we like john whatever he's
producing
john the background that's right now
he's called john baptist yes
good girl thank you my daughter we told
him that you told us he was gay
he's definitely
chocolate souffle was perfect absolutely
amazing texture just really nice and
gooey and choppy in the middle
and the mint choc chip ice cream was a
kind of a throwback to my childhood so
like quite sort of retro a little touch
on the side so it was lovely
i thought the dessert was delicious and
definitely worth five pounds
really beautiful melts in the mouth
really really lovely absolutely give me
the results please
now ladies
justine how do you think we did 50. 50.
yes yes
i hope so you know that i really do we
work hard we did
some of them went out a little bit
lopsided however the flavor was
fantastic for dessert
oh [ __ ] 50 out of 50.
[Music]
oh that is perfection well done 50 out
of 50 for dessert
and good news yeah now we do me a favor
hold on hold on what's in the f-word
hold on
hold on come with me to the dining room
let's go out let's go
okay uh ladies and gentlemen you're set
for this evening yeah
f word series three done
you